[Music]
hey there everybody my name's waffle and
today we're bringing you another first
looks impressions video for the I lords
podcast rad Rodgers world one was
released in January of 2018 so naturally
a port to the popular Nintendo's to
which would be imminent
this platformer slash shooter caught my
attention instantly and I was very
excited to take a look
brought to us by Slipgate and THQ Nordic
thus which version dubbed the rad rogers
radical edition aims to bring us the
wonderful 90s nostalgia that have
brought to the other consoles and PC so
does it do that well let's take a look
let's talk graphics unfortunately for
this game I want to talk about graphics
first and to be honest this is the
versions weakest talking point I
remember playing this game and handheld
mode first this is what I tend to do
since this is the mode I play on the
switch the most and my main thought the
whole time was wow this looks really bad
it's like there's a layer of plastic
wrap on the screen and what's worse the
idea that docking it didn't do it any
favors like it still looks really bad
the textures are very muddy and
sometimes it's hard to tell what it is
that you're looking at especially in
handheld mode I hate that this is the
case because it really doesn't have a
good reason for it I have played plenty
of indie titles with similar art styles
and for the life of me I don't know how
this can be seen as acceptable 9
parchments does it look like this yonder
doesn't look like this earth lock you
know none of these games have this issue
and I'm not I'm not saying this just to
be mean it's just saying like it drags
the whole title down as far as this
games particular art selling direction
it's just kind of met anyways it's
basically only changing the colour of
the forest as you progress and this
makes the game feel a bit samey there
are other characters you can unlock
within the title but they don't seem to
do anything other than add voice lines
what's more the enemies in this game
aren't very varied either it's there's
like a handful of different enemies and
some just take more bullets and others
that's that's like the main thing
in it's just all very met in that
department gameplay-wise
this is where the game really shines as
an action-platformer your game has to
have tight controls and for the most
part this is very true of this title
there are a few times of any that I felt
like I jumped and didn't go where I was
supposed to go the game also utilizes a
gun for rad and I wish I cared more
about this element the gun itself fires
just fine the game offers like different
temporary upgrades for the gun although
I like the idea of them implementing an
RPG element where you can upgrade your
done and things like that that would
make it feel a bit more important like
it's like the gun mattered you know you
can fire with the Y button are the zr
button and this is important because
this helps you aim your gun with the
right stick you still have to take your
thumb off to jump but this adds accuracy
and you know seeing us how this was a PC
game I can see why they want to have
something like that this title that
being said the fact you still take your
thumb off the stick to jump feels of
like a missed opportunity to add another
button for your jump button that way you
could keep your thumb on the stick you
know I mean it's it's just it's weird
it's weird and I feel like they would
have added to the game that being said
the game is full of collectibles from
gems to hats characters and artwork this
game has a lot for you it really wants
you to replay levels Explorer so this
game does have some semblance of replay
value and to be honest it had better
because some of the levels can really
stretch especially if you don't know
where you're going what I mean is the
first level in the game took me 5
minutes tops to complete every level
afterward we'll tired at least 15
minutes and this is because in order to
complete a level you have to collect 4
parts of a key that opens the exit gate
in the first level it was pretty
straightforward I mean you go from left
to right and you basically run into the
key parts as you go but in other levels
it becomes much more of a maze and my
goodness
it can get very frustrating I'm not
proud of this but one level had me
locked into a 30 minute struggle why
because I didn't know that the game had
sub keys these smaller keys open up
doors that lead to the rest of the level
I mistook one of these doors to be an
exit gate and so I searched half of the
level for two key fragments that weren't
there
now don't get me wrong I would take this
upon myself if I could actually see the
keyhole in this ridiculously low
resolution title and this is where
things like graphics can matter but I
digress the game itself is very fun like
I said they're their little puzzles here
and there that I really enjoyed there
are parts of this level that contained
the pixel verse it's like a place with
that dusty which is rad sentient game
console goes to repair missing parts of
the main level these segments are right
like there's nothing too remarkable to
say about them they're mainly like two
forms of one is which like you go
through a maze and search for missing
parts and then the other you have to
connect an electrical puzzle and that
one that kind is much more rewarding I
like that one
much better in between levels are little
mini games you can do like some are
memory games others or like a pogo stick
thing there's like even like a pinball
game so there's that if you're into
mini-games lastly I will mention that
you can play this game in coop so if you
have someone you'd like to play this
title with there you go you can do that
there's the battle modes and you can
also work together
this game is not for children do not let
the boxart fool you this game is very
very much made by fans of conker and you
can tell that aside from the profanity
and there is lots of it there's plenty
of crude humor sometimes it's like a
simple joke about rap being ugly other
times it's like a quip about the items
within the game being what plugs I kid
you not together those a series joke
within this and I mean I guess the
reason it worked in conker was because
heels a squirrel and rat himself is a
child rad he doesn't really say anything
bad outside of you know the regular
let's kick some ass things but the other
characters make these jokes too rabbit
and that's the part that I find slightly
off-putting the jokes are funny but
they're very grown funny and it's it's
just something you have to keep in mind
lastly the music within the game is very
much 90s fun there are a few melodies
there that got stuck in my head but
overall so those are my thoughts on rad
Rodgers radical edition is it perfect
no but is it fun yes very much so and
that's that's a big take away here
honestly my biggest problem is just the
muddy visuals I think it's it's just
it's just enough to really annoy me and
that's that's the worst part of it
because like I said you've seen better
there's no there's no real excuse for
this but overall the game will appeal to
anyone who loves platformers and loves
crude humor I mean you you better be
ready laughs it really is a very funny
title a little cringy but that's mainly
because of the character thing that I
was talking about before so yeah thank
you so much for watching and make sure
to catch the iron woods podcast every
Sunday at 1 p.m.
[Music]